[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the philosopher's stone
hogwarts professor quironus quirrell the
dark lord voldemort and of course harry
potter queerness quirrell was an english
half-blood wizard born sometime in the
1960s when he was of age he began
attending hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry at which point he was
sorted into ravenclaw house quirrell was
a highly unusual and delicate but
talented student and was teased
profusely at school making the anxious
quirrell even more anxious
not long after graduating himself a
young quirrell was able to secure a job
as the muggle studies professor at
hogwarts however in the year 1990
quirrell took a year-long sabbatical he
told his peers that the sabbatical was
an opportunity for him to gain
first-hand experience in the field where
in reality his objective was to find
lord voldemort exceedingly curious about
what had happened to the dark lord who
tyrannized the wizarding world for years
on end however his trip changed quirrell
in fact it destroyed him he sought
voldemort to earn the respect of others
but in the process it became just
another one of voldemort's pawns
voldemort recounts his first meeting
with quirrell a wizard young foolish and
gullible wandered across my path in the
forest i'd made my home
oh he seemed the very chance i'd been
dreaming of for he was a teacher at
dumbledore's school he was easy to bend
to my will he brought me back to this
country and after a while i took
possession of his body to supervise him
closely as he carried out my orders and
when quirrell returned to hogwarts
school after travelling the other
professors seemed to notice that he
wasn't quite the same hagrid recounts
crow's nature after returning home from
his travels oh yeah poor bloke brilliant
mind he was fine while he was studying
out of books but then he took a year off
to get some first-hand experience they
say he met vampires in the black forest
there was a nasty bit of trouble with a
hag never been the same since when
quirrell began teaching again at
hogwarts he didn't reprise his role as
muggle studies professor instead he
began his new role as defense against
the dark arts professor
the year that quirrell became a data
professor was the same year that harry
had his foundational year at hogwarts at
one point after hagrid picks harry up
and brings him to diagon alley the two
find themselves in the leaky cauldron
where harry has his first interaction
with quirrell a pale young man made his
way forward very nervously one of his
eyes was twitching professor quirrell
said hagrid harry professor quirrell
will be one of your teachers at hogwarts
potter stammered professor quirrell
grasping harry's hand
can't tell you how pleased i am to meet
you as we can clearly see in the passage
above quirrell and harry's hands made
contact but this poses a new question
how we know that towards the end of the
philosopher's stone harry's touch is
enough to kill quirrell quibble raised
his hand to perform a deadly curse but
harry by instinct reached up and grabbed
quirrell's face ah
quirrell rolled off of him his face
blistering too and then harry knew
grubble couldn't touch his bare skin not
without suffering terrible pain his only
chance was to keep hold of quirrell keep
him in enough pain to stop him doing a
curse so i think the question here is
why was quirrell able to shake harry's
hand earlier in the film when later on
it was enough to kill him let's dive in
and figure this out the answer put quite
succinctly is that quirrell though
following voldemort's orders was not yet
entirely possessed by voldemort when he
shook harry's hand in the leaky cauldron
if we go back before the school year
began then you'll remember that there
was an attempted break-in at gringotts
an effort to steal the philosopher's
stone this attempt at stealing the stone
however was thwarted when hagrid emptied
the vault it was only after quirrell's
attempt to steal the stone and
voldemort's subsequent disappointment
that he decided to possess him quirrell
mentions this to harry himself he does
not forgive mistakes easily when i
failed to steal the stone from gringotts
he was most displeased he punished me
decided he would have to keep a closer
watch on me anyway i hope that clears up
any confusion about their handshake what
video do you guys want next comment down
below also be sure to like the video and
subscribe to the channel for future
content one more thing i want to mention
is that i've been posting lots on my
mythology channel so go check that out
as well link in the pinned comment until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you